something very odd is going on this
thing with Jackson the wife probably
doesn't want to be in the same house
with us and the father as a nervous
wreck I'm sure that's not it
no it's there's something else it's that
something about the father and the
butler I can't put my finger all this
messing what do you mean it's nothing is
nothing you always think the word I
don't always think you are through the
worst girl's mother is just ocean weed
young ladies fails mother was just a
little late you want to speak up excuse
me
well we'll let's give her a half an hour
and then she isn't here I am oh please
forgive me for being so late but the
traffic was unbelievable senator Keeley
mrs. Kealey ah I'm so happy to meet you
at last it oh you must be Barbara what a
pretty child yeah come here he give me
hug
oh don't be afraid oh how adorable she's
shy it's so nice to meet you mrs.
Coleman Goldman I thought the D was
silent it is pronounced Coleman isn't it
we've had some confusion oh yes Coleman
the D is silent in America it's called
Elim or or coal of the Isle of Man in
France where our mom's Chateau is and
Coldman in Greece where our mom's work
is and finally the Volga Coleman in
Florida where our man's home is so
actually we don't know where we are
until we hear our last name pronounced
oh that explains it at last oh I think I
would like to hug you mrs. Coleman oh my
dear child oh well
you
you
you